à cuba la fin du système unique des deux
monnaies génie fication monétaire entre
en vigueur aujourd'hui depuis plus de
vingt ans de mauvaise foi circulation
sur l'île mais d'ici à six mois il ne
restera que le peso cuba mais en pleine
crise économique c'est un pari risqué
pour le gouvernement socialiste cubain
les précisions de meriem laribi cuba va
mettre en oeuvre une importante réforme
économique que l'on peut qualifier
d'historique et dont le but affiché est
d'actualiser l'économie cubaine le pays
va entamer son processus d'unification
monétaire ce 1er janvier en effet depuis
1994 il y avait deux monnaies en
circulation à cuba le peso cubain et le
peso convertible ce peso convertible
qu'il s'échangeait à un contre un contre
avec le dollar et qui était
principalement utilisés par les
étrangers par les touristes va
disparaître le 1er janvier et il ne
restera plus alors que le peso cubain
pour tout le monde
cette mesure est destinée à rendre
l'économie cubaine plus lisible pour les
investisseurs étrangers
elle sera accompagnée d'autres mesures
dont on peut retenir dans les grandes
lignes donc une dévaluation qui
découlera de cette unification monétaire
et cette dévaluation vaincre un fait
craindre une forte inflation mais les
autorités cubaines ont assuré qu'elle
afficherait la plus grande sévérité
contre la spéculation notamment dans le
marché noir
il y aura également une suppression
progressive des subventions publiques en
cours a plus bas depuis des décennies et
enfin pour permettre à la population
d'absorber les conséquences d'une
éventuelle hausse des prix est bien des
salaires et les retraites vont être
multipliées par cinq a annoncé le
gouvernement cubain
mais le président miguel des as cannes
elle a prévenu que l'unification
monétaire ne serait pas la solution
magique à tous les problèmes économiques
du pays
c'est en effet une réforme majeure est
risqué pour le gouvernement socialiste
qui tente actuellement de rassurer la
population sur le fait qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un programme d'ajustement
néolibérale